human in sharp soup in short we make
smash mash
you
should I say that hello
everybody.welcome GameSpot pre III week
what's up how's it going
not much Jake yeah I'm John Luke he's
Jake it's pretty hectic in the office
but we are going to be playing some
Gwent yeah we cut out a bit of time to
play through this yeah both of us have
been having a lot of fun with this and
we got 40 kegs that we're going to open
later in the stream yes so stick around
for that very excited about that but to
kick things off we're just gonna play a
couple casual matches yeah this is a the
open open beta essentially a soft launch
for the game there they're not going to
reset everything like they did with the
closed beta uh but you know they still
might make changes and they're the
official launch will come with like the
single-player and yeah like that with
part 1 of the single-player supposed to
be 5 different campaigns are for
different
oh really ain't no wow okay but those
will cost money but this is free so if
you have it totally up you have a place
to haunt yeah I'm assuming you've got
something that'll play this cuz yeah
excitation Xbox one PC and PC we're
playing on PC by the way for anyone
curious yes I am gonna be reading the
comments so if you have any questions
feel free to hit us up hopefully whoever
we're playing doesn't realize we're
streaming and then login to the stream
and then look at the cards I have cuz
that would be mean I was trying to
figure out a way I was like me back at
Rick I get like hi something you know
people to like play with us right like
oh you wanna play with us yes that'd be
the issue also I couldn't think of a way
to do it like cleanly efficiently that
the best way to do it is games with like
a party like where you can yeah Bobby
cuz you'd be like hey just join this
lobby oh yeah but trying to deal with
like friend invites and all that's
that's a bit messy goom's in the chat
sup Gabe did you see who we're playing
was it monsters yes you're playing
monsters then I shouldn't have gotten
rid of that well you can also hide your
cards actually - look that's what I
should have done
damn but I recognized the music
because this is this is my weakness is
is whether cards because I don't play I
don't have anything in my deck to
counter whether cards because the only I
feel like monsters the only one that
ever use whether card yeah I I play
monster what is it now go start with
this guy a Grand Master Witcher good
good user in so the actual in-game Gwent
is kind of better I mean it's very
different like did the issue with the
actual in-game when I find is that it
doesn't hold up outside of playing
against AI oh yeah it's it's not very
balanced at all yeah I mean that it's
designed to z8 thing that you get better
cards over time like the cards you play
at the beginning of that you know like
ones and twos like it yeah it's like
this wouldn't actually make any sense
yeah an actual you know trading card
game that's fine took out the shields
whatever wait got so wants to know is
the same game from the games I mean
Witcher 3 as it same rules uh basically
yes lots and lots of tweaks in additions
and but it is still you start out with
ten cards and you bet to me that you get
to draw a little bit but that's really
what you're stuck with yes
for the rest of the game so it's very
much a game of like management yeah in
weapon management I could not I don't
need card management probably makes more
sense yeah yeah has the multiple rounds
in the different ways some basic friends
just yeah tweaks and stuff scheme also
is a really pretty pretty good tutorial
that kind of like breaks down it does
yeah and you get to hear a Geraldton
series voice again which is kind of cool
yeah that is worth I wonder if the jimta
story I was gonna have boy stuff yes
it'll be voiced I think for the most
part but you won't play as Geralt only
I'm assuming they're gonna be one where
you're gonna play as Geralt but yeah
it's kind of swapping back and forth um
so yeah like each campaign will feature
a different protagonist she's kind of
cool actually have they shown anything
from the campaign I don't know I've seen
some of it but I don't know if that was
I'm assuming they'll show it soon but
maybe they'll show it later we just
found out that apparently yeah the CD
Projekt RED is gonna have like an update
livestream in like an hour so yeah
welcome to the pre the pre stream we're
gonna be playing quiet all right this
guy doesn't seem too dependent on was
first rounds we're still in the first
round on you guys are going for it
yeah I might pass I should have given
this wall I'm not really paying much
attention but I should have given the
swallow to him I mean I am paying
attention but like right yeah my mind is
on two different things at the moment
but I gave swallow to him instead so he
got bigger and then whatever we'll see
how it goes
okay that's fine you can do that I can
do I'm gonna play this card this card is
clutch they call me I count for them
yeah so what he does is either I can so
any of my card that's either hurt or
like boosted I can play it on that card
and it'll go back to its standard thing
and +3 but if I do it to an enemy it
goes back to its standard attack and
then minus 3 so it do do right there he
is like I think a 1 or something like
that
so but he copies whatever I have and
since I did that he just got nuked
basically Griffin in the twitch chat
says there was a small preview of the
campaign at the end of a recent video ok
I'm showing a little okay um but it
looks really cool I don't know if I
should play more I might just pass cuz
he's gonna have to play another card if
he wants to beat me
do you think they will so I was thinking
about this the The Witcher TV show they
announced that's based on the books
that is based on the books and I don't
think CD Projekt RED has a hand in that
they don't at all but do you think they
will make any sort of nods to the games
like went for example which was fully
made up or spicy Projekt RED went on in
the books um I think so there is a card
game in the books that they like kind of
right but it's not Gwen yeah I don't
think they'll mention Gwen but I have a
feeling they'll probably talk about
barrel which was yeah I don't think it
was it its barrel it barrel was its
translation I don't know actually yeah I
think when it was clearly like inspired
by that yeah but it's not like the same
so yeah maybe they'll just like yeah
they'll call it a barrel or whatever
yeah Sam in the books give me something
good I think I got I can't see what that
is I kind of don't like how when they're
redrawing it just graze everything out
yeah City much to look at um opponents
to see what you got they need the Gwen
song from the game actually they have it
in this shadow monarch if you go to the
options there is a I think it's an audio
or gameplay settings you can click a
button that says play Witcher 3 Quentin
yes so then I know what we're doing
right and I should do that right now so
stick around wishes granted uh somebody
says hearthstone copy uh actually so I
played a decent mount hearthstone and I
mean on some degree trading card games
are kind of always a copy of a copy of a
copy right but there is I like this
game's round based structure because I
always feel like you can come back from
it you know if you're gonna be bad for
his round but then it's kind of like the
only sense yeah couple you asking about
full viz
so know who this is not the full
releases the open beta it's essentially
a soft launch like with the closed beta
they they like reset everyone's stuff at
the end yeah so if you were in the
closed beta you haven't played in a
while you go back to it it
very different game they've added a lot
because I played the closed beta quite a
bit when it first came out but I didn't
play it at all after that and then I
came back here playing it and a lot has
changed yeah
Oh baby this is good this is gonna piss
him off as far as a full release goes
they have just said 2017 they have not
given an official release date so far I
think I've got him like what's like week
yeah I think everyone waited you in the
first one yeah he won the yeah
that means I have done this yeah you got
one I think I'll be okay maybe not yeah
goob there's no harm in checking yeah I
mean it's free yeah just download it and
end so my biggest issue with this is
that it's on so it's on PC it's on
PlayStation 4 and it's on Xbox one
your humble and they're the exact same
versions that calls versions actually it
feels pretty good playing it on a
controller actually yeah you can also
plug in a controller on PC which was I
was doing at but my issue is that there
is no like cross play in terms of like a
shared account so there's times where
I'm like well I feel like I should
invest in the PC version because I have
access to it on PCs and I can kind of
play it like that's an easier way to
play with games but I like the casual
nature of just being able to turn on my
playstation and do like I'll just play
around a Gwen on my TV or something so
having to be forced to pick which one I
want to invest in in terms of like
getting card packs and all that stuff
like kind of sucks that's a bummer the
only way they could ever make that work
is if I actually created like a
like in-game account system which at
this point I don't think they're going
to do that unfortunately um is that
recording what is it pretty cool cuz
it's a good game is like a I got you
curious what he's gonna do and let's see
for fits is going on sums banging on the
walls around here he made for fit well
we got the game library the nick of the
Nick margarita memorial right okay
should I just like rub it in and start
playing the rest of my cards a show oh
that's a bad thing to do I do it against
the computers a long time yeah we won
woo Eric hey didn't think I was gonna
win so in that good game man Yeltsin a
good game did I send it oh he didn't
send you and send you back though he
told me oh no he did sent it right get
some extra scrap that is one thing that
I haven't been able to dig into it all
cuz you have to be level three before
you start like scrapping cards and right
yeah yeah I was I was determined to get
to level three so I could at least scrap
spare cards which I am at but I had
other legendary cards like yennefer or
gerald yes I can show you some so Gert
yeah totally um the gold cards are I
think they refer to they refer to them
as a legendary or special card full just
gold cards cards yeah there's multiple
Geralt cards actually cuz there's yeah
there's garel and then there's all of
Geralt magic abilities as separate cards
um yes so a lot like you usually get one
like when you start you have each like
started that comes with one that's
specific to each deck right so with no
forgets key here but then you also start
out with Tris Geralt and you start out
with this dude who lets you play a gold
card which you actually start with a
premium girl you should swap it out with
the premium version do you not have a
premium girl I don't have a prune girl
I'll have a premium girl and then I drew
bill I've never been even when I was
reading the books that could never
pronounce this then
in true tension ten mirth yeah don't
yeah mm-hmm but that's the dragon that
they were showing off a lot um what I
want a premium premium garel I how did I
get that premium girl pen so for those
who don't know uh the every card has a
premium version where like it's animated
hey they look cool they look really cool
we'll probably get some Wii and start
opening boxes and every card has a
version of that that you have to there's
a separate resource
it's like meteorite powder that you use
just to get those yeah you can you'll
eventually get enough playing the game
has a pretty good system of like daily
tier rewards that you can play to unlock
stuff like that so can absolutely get
that stuff without paying money but they
also have in addition to my fine heads
which are like their card packs they
also have a separate menu just for
buying the meteorite powder because they
know people want those yeah sweet oh
yeah you have a premium swallow I do
have prunes well that when I pulled
someone set in their grand master
Richard said who still played you didn't
get the music Oh should I forgot it's
too late um yeah but I still play The
Witcher 3 you just you just I just
recently decided I should stop playing
it recently uh ah premium Garrett was an
award for the closed beta what oh I
played it on a different account that's
why ah does he say I played it on yeah
dang Thank You team is I am starting
okay
let's start with this guy okay when he
goes the gravy I can get strengthened by
three that's the biggest problem I have
with my monster deck at the moment is I
have all of my cards are dependent on
like other car or like in terms of
getting their bonuses so I always feel
like I have to I don't have like a good
like base yeah you know cards to put I'm
like oh like I feel like I have to
sacrifices Freya is nobody but she
Brooks isn't well this guy just made it
easy for me cuz he immediately
electrocuted him so I just brought him
back and now he's a nine alex says
normal garel is a good gold starter but
I usually replace later on yeah he's
like a good starter to start a character
our spies still an option in the game
yes but they work very differently it's
not like in The Witcher 3 where you draw
cards instead it's more like you play
something on the other side and then you
get a benefit like the previous game I
played those cards where I placed one on
the other side and then my creature
increased by 10 or whatever see I hate
freakin someone says you monster -
monster attacks are dope that's what I
play i I think I over played monster
decks and Witcher 3 and so I like having
them playing them but right that is the
other thing is they seem like they've
done a damn good job balancing out all
of the different decks yeah yes where
there there's like legitimate reasons to
like play everyone as opposed to you
know 3 words like well gotta play
monster deck yeah I don't think I'm
gonna win this like I'm ahead now maybe
I'll pass after this unless you can't
play something that
[Music]
oops it's got to relearn this Gwen yeah
it's a it didn't really take that much
though to relearn it for me especially
cuz I got some potatoes actually yeah I
should pass rose rose hmm pass now
so it says why does the frost card only
affect your side so frost weather cards
only affect what particular lane
yeah so it's not like before where it
would affect both I do not like the
music that plays just gonna pass when we
find monster decks it's like this weird
don't you done but they do your um like
monster eyes get here like that I might
listening to this no not good no this is
not a good game for me what I need is I
don't want three of these cards well I
guess three is okay goob is shocked one
side to whether cards yes
very different I need some what I need
I'm just like my strategy for this deck
is not like I've yeah I should have paid
more attention during redrawing because
this is not good because normally what I
do with this guy
is all week in my own things cuz I have
another guy that boosts my weakened ones
cuz he can do one damage to three but
it's not going well
Louie says this game should be on a hobo
leg very cool mercies puss and sprite
time I don't know how busy this would
look on my phone like compressed um
should we play a match against the
creator of Gwent yes all right so lutely
I'm gonna do em him right now he just
replied to
this because I want watch you lose I'm
gonna we're I'm gonna lose he'll do you
mind driving for a second while I figure
this out no you're well I have no
strategy right now okay well um Kate can
either rip Oh apologies I've never this
is a Skellig attack um uh and I'm not
I've not played it
yeah like listen to this music I did
yeah oh god that's so weird what happens
if by some miracle Jake wins it won't
happen because I don't have to win this
one um what's through strategy here
there's no strategy so with these guys I
have another card that I draw two and
discard two cards so if these cards
right I just discard them immediately go
onto the battlefield but I highest loyal
unit in your deck strengthener by three
than doing this is good this is really
good
yeah maybe do that and then use Oliver
well oh wait now you can't look at what
your deck and won't that make sense why
would they let you do that
I guess just keep putting these down
right yes bored just stomping here I
think we can no I don't think we're
gonna win this round uh other ants is
the Skellig a storm weather Cardon air
now I got played my ripoff of you yo man
I'm trying to remember I play together
I played it played a good amount of UDL
yeah you Gail's the one where I never
remember the rules
I got so kind of remember magic
yeah I'm really hard smiling along but
I'm trying to take like how do you play
you Gilligan
all I remember with you go is you had
the like sacrifice creature and played
burger monsters right and yeah cuz like
yeah you had to like add up the stars or
whatever the sacrifices were just kind
of okay by the rates of more Jodi uh I
walked way more of the show yeah yeah
watch a lot of the show's lost lost bad
just worth it man No
all right I'll be nice all right nice
and even when I'm another person I'm
just like four feet long hood after this
can we cut to camera I'm gonna add I'm
gonna add developer
he says he's watching the stream but he
promise you will not peek when we bought
all right before that though oh yeah you
need it let me change the music so if
you go to options here settings oh there
it is that's so cool really music that
is rad so now we have that enabled cool
all right I'm gonna cut to uh just the
camera no that's not the camera
oh that's the okay your things broken
the camera goes to nothing there we go
all right okay cool okay I'll have to
fix that later blame tag um give me one
second why for those of us just joining
we are adding the creator of Gwent so
that we can play a round with him watch
Jake lose or win I've played them before
and I got my bucket oh my god chase s is
wanted that's why goes to nothing okay
send them in a friend invite all right
let me
man you're on you're on a messenger like
that's how tight you guys are oh no that
was Twitter House Twitter put a damn
okay Simon Furman quest we're just gonna
wait a little bit you know there it is
go back to back to the game where yes um
OOP don't know [ __ ]
but let me thought up there we go just
give their PSN nein sorry we do not uh
invite sent are not we're currently not
playing it on the PlayStation Network so
that's the weird thing is you can um
this game has crossed play you can play
like PC can play against PlayStation you
can play against Xbox apparently Xbox
and PlayStation can't play probably
because the council's
they don't like to get along with each
other nicly could kind of a shame
shaming with rocket League right like
you could play with right with rocket
League you could set up a lobby that
anyone could not anyone could join but
like like if I'm playing on PC and
you're playing on ps4 I can set up a
lobby with a password that you can get
in oh um but with this I don't know
maybe go out of it yeah but uh the weird
thing is I don't know Hansel I don't
know how you would even though I can
technically play with PlayStation people
I don't know how invite them you know or
how I would know I'm playing yeah
against them
Oh 10 makes a good point he says we
should have open the kegs early to get
more cards oh yeah I'm definitely gonna
slow
whoo all right man what are you gonna
what again
so I think I'm gonna do my new friend
Jack because I feel like it it's a
little bit better I can rely on the
strategy all right more on this one so
we're gonna be playing against the
creator of glad food one of the
co-creators of oil let's see how we do
my men know them you know he's playing
will sacrifice the North Shore tuck tail
and I still I still don't have that
leader card the more in Voorhees right I
like that one a lot more than this
although I'm warming up to this guy
because there are some cool strategies
you can do with them other manses are
other microtransactions you can buy car
packs of the same way you can with
hearthstone and then there's also
meteorite powder which is what you would
use to get the premium cards that have
like you know that are animated but you
can also get those just by playing as
well so you like hearthstone you can
play this whole game without paying
money if you want just I should have
seen my level is not [ __ ] off to a good
start man oh dude to the front yet again
23 to 8 all right
okay nice Ted up to
what's your strategy here what are you
thinking so I think what I'm gonna leave
above all to be chopped oh I was okay
alright I think I'm gonna try to boost
this guy as much as you can and then
keep aiming for next round I just pass
okay but he's at 31 and he stills nine
cards in San yet billions okay it's not
a bad you know trying to friend turn
around give me a little bit of a head
start for round two
you'll need it yup first let cool that's
Don wants to know can you fuse regular
cards in a premium or how do you get
them yes and can you confuse regular
cards into premium cards so you got you
take the car you transmute it with your
powder to turn it into a premium card oh
oh oh man oh well I can still come back
from this John Luke skill Abraxas you've
lost around but you'll win the war etc
etc I don't think so okay let's let's
plate it a shame yet I have no time okay
I kind of like both of them now mm-hmm
hey katsu
I don't think he's got another burn card
I don't think he'll build a burner
I didn't arrest insurance yeah he does
he's got enough oh okay please wait your
excellency I'm falling behind I'll take
him oh boy it's got a pretty good deck
yeh does we definitely should have
opened those card packs first maybe we
could to get a rematch later
I don't know how busy he is or what time
it is that right they're doing it
they're doing a live stream that's true
we all know maybe that shows something
they're doing it out of there I can give
an LA office probably doing it out of
there cuz I think it's like it's got to
be like really nine hours ahead right or
nine hours behind I don't know it's over
for me
mmm highly curious case I'll play one of
his cards I don't know it when this card
is revealed plate in draw card
a shame I had no time what is it now
alright I think he's gonna pass yeah
it's the only way you even get I'm gonna
have to like use the rest of my car as
yesterday not passing wants to win this
round
man brutal oh he's just trying to
revealed it he just revealed the rest of
my cards well oh I'll zap him I know
what I can do next time I think I can
unless he unless keeps going this round
too I shall do what I must
man this means good alright aggro told
doom anime s best Hale character people
asking about price it's a free yeah free
game
yep download Gog and then there you go
yep or a Playstation or Xbox down let
you're good to go
always passing well I mean I might as
well try to win this round yes like
you're not going to win but you know and
he's gonna start with that at ten I
wonder if there's a way I can at least
injure it a little bit
well one around and he knows what I have
to doesn't know I have first light Oh
gonna I'm just gonna save me definitely
which looks like I got to swallow no I
got okay
oh no we're gonna set out with this ax
em I'll do as you ask
least what's his name uh we're blank
yeah put their football fall I hope I'm
pronouncing it right okay GUP says he
got him right where you want him
I don't even know what to do my
prescription a [ __ ] ability man I don't
know D I don't know off to the fray yet
again something of a portable triumph is
must triumph curses
the North shall dante exum mercy a
glottal doom anime s best Hale character
okay
look at this though mmm yeah mmm
highly curious case Chas ruin for you
could I have some support all right
your trump card now's the time I like
ice cream anything I am also be just
play whatever we played on that well
that's that Oh
owner if do friend matches count towards
ah you lost I did
well that was pretty good uh thank you
so much for playing for kicking Jake's
ass
egg went so sorry perfect
I'll see if you wants to do one more and
it will open up some kegs do you want to
try it well I don't want to take it this
time though um yeah let me yeah well I
think we should get to that we should
get to those keg openings I got 40 of
them yeah we do have a lot to get
through people are commenting I'll help
the soundtrack is awesome yes alright I
don't know if it's the same composer who
did a Witcher 3 but definitely invokes
the same yeah feeling for sure
okay will do we're gonna do one more
with him and then we will i'll get my
butt kicked again okay my man doing a
rematch I'm not gonna use the same deck
yes
mix it up I'll use my other one which
isn't as prepared oh he said yeah it's
it's the same composer who did the oh
thank you I think that's the same
composer
sorry give us give us one minute I'm
trying waiting for him to get this match
gone yeah
so instead of opening kegs is really
really slow like stupid slow yeah we're
probably not going to open all for MP
and we'll see we'll see how I was
feeling it takes yeah you're right that
it is painfully slow yeah it is a bit
slow like you don't think about it when
you only open like four or five and
forty ovum 14 it's like whoa gonna be
here a while
[Music]
too good
uh yeah he's getting off the stream so
he won't peek ah
I'll just tell him and send me an invite
in the meantime we can elder man yes
kegs are like Max yeah open up a couple
should we do it I don't wanna start
opening everything now yeah the invite I
also have one I can cash in with my
hundred and seventy so we can open 41
goob no we're gonna play what dick are
you gonna play I'm gonna do the my I'm
gonna do my there we go there it is I'm
gonna do my spy Krug's battalion I love
it which is Skellig ax
but I played it before and as you can
see if I don't get the right cards I
can't really do much with it so I'm
since you're not pronouncing a ripe it's
still decent not sure it's why your
friends you but yeah probably whatever I
didn't say right yeah we're playing a
the PC version right now someone in the
chat was asking I saw and uh elder man
yes there's campaign mode it's not in
right now but it is planning on being
available at the official like full
launch oh I think he's playing the same
deck our IP others campaign low mode we
unlock leader abilities yes so there is
a new you with us in a challenge mode
that you can play to unlock yeah you get
like something else and you get leader
cards because not a like story campaign
mode which they are playing on that the
likes of over six under and Sprite gain
just more story more with your story
like enough for me oh all right I got
the strategy going here I think I unless
he just burns both these and then
there's a little sweet all he locked his
ability no well played
well I can at least throw him down we
agreed up fire iron iron I like all that
little stuff if they say get me two adds
a little bit a little bit of character
to the yeah all right
are you guys like how can you guys
scream iam yeah
I've never got a premium from a card
pack I don't know if this will be enough
- we didn't want to do a math right now
9:28 dang gotta play another cards in
people asking where you can get this
game pc and just go get it on gone I
don't know if it's still happening but
they have a thing once they like last
week where if you like got a copy gwen
and you signed up for like their
newsletter or something you got a free
copy of The Witcher 1 oh yeah I did see
that yeah I don't know if it's still
going yeah which I already owned so I
actually just gave it to my brother
who's never played The Witcher games why
don't have these cards no no oh wait a
minute yeah I already draw one I guess
yeah wait yeah I don't know how I got
them did he put them in there yeah I
mean it must have been some ability he
must have put them in los Lorde's he
knows I have it my display
my man knows meaning sucks nice off to
the front yet uh he says I was I can't
even aim he says he feels like Skellig
ax is most Opie I think I think nofe
guard is at least I've had it on this
deck not even based on this deck but I
usually have the most trouble with me
off guard but I think nofe guard is a
lot harder to play it's my tarnish do
something I compared to the previous
versions of the game creatively it's
like that's what I like about it is that
yes there's definitely still some like
clear you know tweaks and balance and
good name for balancing but I feel like
every deck has like a good language it
sure sees and
we're like um like Sequoia tell you know
yeah it's like kind of like an at the
beginning so this is cool he stole my
card but since he locked it it stayed
locked and it didn't get its three
strength so cuz he resurrected it from
my graveyard
she's kind of cool I mean it means he
doesn't have three extra points he
misses and they gave Witcher 2 for free
for everyone who tested the game in the
closed beta which I also did but I
already owned it so we saw at school a
scourge and mother and Crone willing to
give that stuff away
Elda man has got to go
thanks for joining us yeah thank you for
stopping by yeah burned a Robert said I
wasn't I wasn't pronouncing the
developers name right by the rates of
more oh okay that's that's what we
weren't pronouncing I want to try then I
won't try again yeah and II D polish is
hard for hitting mysterious all Rocha
meals card
on worch
what's your strategy here man
I've got no strategy anymore all right
so you got that first round yeah but I
did I did burn through connect I fall to
be just okay it seems like the chat is
going back and forth between oaf garden
no friends to kill ago that's the - ah
to beat I play monster
I like monster quite a bit yeah before
monster was the one that was tough to be
even during the closed beta
Gupta's new strategy get five gold cards
to drop in the last row only issue with
that is it only have four gold cards in
your deck right all right final round
you only get one more card it was a gold
card though I was a gold card but it's
not a gold card that'll actually might
come in handy
no it won't hmm and won't come in handy
draw two cards including bowls and draw
it now that's not gonna help
you're right I shall do what I'm not o
reveal my car's sake
well he knows what I have any last words
oh I should have waited to play Geralt
actually he's got that grave ability a
bit of bloodletting Kiki says I'm sad no
one plays monster I do
happily play I feel like monsters what I
mostly see online actually maybe not so
much anymore
oh yeah see too much monster I feel like
actually so far I feel like on lines
been pretty all over the place yeah I
haven't seen yeah actually I think
northern realms I haven't seen a lot of
home line yeah portable triumphs I see
what I cannot escape out which is
surprising cuz I remember I see boys
tell Israel it was not very good in The
Witcher at least I didn't think is very
good in The Witcher 3 but it was pretty
good in the closed beta I remember
having a lot of fun with that we greet
everybody at spire 9 well I put up a
better fight this yes put of a much
better fight but he got me again
uh-huh yeah a little closer that little
closer though Oh
get another card though see oh no I lost
but not as bad all right those are good
games have we're able to play with them
yeah cool all right
shall we start opening some keg lands
open some kegs the moment people have
been waiting for what am i doing I'm
messaging thank you really quickly if
you want to do want me to get started on
opening these okay let's do it
so all right perfect
okay it's a good a good sign
okay Judy ass monster okay what do you
want for this I already own a couple of
them um that were no it's not this mouse
like click on it it's like not yeah yeah
he's gonna go for a bit how come mr.
field card so I don't understand this
root that's what he was using using the
reveal strategy I don't really
understand too much I feel like they
should
oh yeah you know some top to your
strategy there alright so I have to take
that
oh yeah it's pretty bad of course I
really like these cards yeah I mean yeah
you take three medium gray taken I'm
thinking in forty kegs we'll probably
get another one of those premium I hope
so you're right something is up yeah
some of the mouse is like it's probably
why it was the graphic maybe try pulling
really control yet um it's I have not
it's pretty good good biting frost yeah
key for my loss here my monster deck
spawn a cow carcass
I don't know this is your first four oh
you're right duh well that's really cool
man you already got another Wow I'm so
jealous you're the one who gets to do
this here over opens my eye I think I've
yet to uh I've been on a couple streams
where we've open car packs by get to
opening what do you want here okay um I
think the the co-creator might stick
around the chat so if you guys have
questions he should be in there and he's
gonna help us pick cards as well - cool
yeah which chap the twit sure the twitch
chat yes okay here um the only issue
with helping us pick cards the delay
unfortunately yeah um yeah that's a good
point
I normally just pick things that benefit
my probably shouldn't but on deck
okay yeah I think me check sorry about
this I'm gonna see if he's in twitch
chat
whoa oh that's three silvers hmm it's
timer damage if they're all good I kind
of want margarita just because yeah yeah
all right
the supernovae and the chances always go
premium you said take octave it's too
late huh I don't know how all that'll
work they'll be more of him giving us
like pro tips they set out too late
don't worry oh that's so cool can I have
that premium one damn dude yeah I I
didn't get any premium cards from
barrels and you've been getting a lot I
think you know what the so let's ask me
out how the armor mechanic works so it
doesn't add points to your score right
the armor no it doesn't add points to
your score it's just like oh it's just
like a buffer if you have an eight with
a three armor it's still an eight but
it's got a little like buffer so if
someone hits it three times
yeah um I really like see I don't play
that deck but I really like the blue
stripes commander but yeah I don't like
this one I think is gonna fit my Skellig
attack sir no sir I did I fought against
the blue stripe deck in the challenge
mode and that was like a fun back to
fight yeah and I was like whew that's
what's cool hey Adam I wanna give a
count out the co-creator is in the chat
and twitch chat so if you're in twitch
chat and you have any questions uh feel
free to drop them a question he's gonna
help us pick two but as as we kind of
figured out so far this kind of a delay
and yeah there's enough of a delay and
we don't want to like sit here
hmm
boost self by 2 when you play spying
unit that I feel like would work well
with mine yeah we're gonna take that oh
but uh there was um they one of the
challenge decks had oh he told me to
take them universe had 30 different
Witcher cards like vesemir and then got
the names of the moment the two other
witcher's and basically their abilities
was like if you summon one it's
someone's the other three Witcher car oh
yeah up m1 something that's cool yeah
are they are they a certain uh what if
we can time how long the delay is blood
curling or destroy an ally spawn a bear
oh I bet it spawns it on their side
oh yeah I want this car
lambie's is Lambert mescal Lambert
Haskell yes thank you thank you I was
like like I was like I can picture that
I can picture their faces looks like Oh
what is their names what do we have 31
we still got a ways to go
oh we got a oh you got a a premium
biting frost I don't know because my
monster deca is biting frost I'm like I
feel like I want that yeah premium
looking uh why not
alright we've done ten oh god he said
last night took lacerate awesome
I like this fun game we're playing yeah
I know he picked the card and then we
just hope it's right was the right one
oh dude uh that's yeah that's super cool
I already have one but you don't have
probably well I think they count
differently like I think you count - yes
I think I have to print owner if that'll
get me extra scraps though if I I think
so
they said premium I I think always yep
piece is always always premium so that's
expensive
I've been doing a lot of them damn man
Wow another brain I'm getting lucky okay
question is if you buy like a is there
like an increased chance of premiums if
you buy like a huge like chunk of them
well when I was getting the barrels
because I've never gotten a premium
so when I cuz I got 20 before this like
a couple days ago when I first
downloaded it because I wanted to make a
deck and I did not get many he and now
what do I pick Oh - premiums whoa all
right he says now so he's just super
lucky you're just apparently you're just
like I'm just getting lunch extreme
magic Jake's the stream magic this is
what the people want though yeah they
want even he even he's like okay he said
I take done I don't know if I did know I
think you didn't take it he all right
I'm gonna take him
my first day playing got three
Legendary's and I'd fairy lights as a
bad luck I've gotten I've gotten two so
far one was another like Tris though it
was like this Kara like the normal ones
uh
and then bill that one I couldn't
pronounce that dragon right Oh another
premium so upset a year now
again all these premium cards we read 25
we're making our way all right
this mouse yeah you can plug in the
controller if you want I don't know if
we have all we have the cable I don't we
have a cable in here oh I got a Quentin
sign another one so I think I already
have four of those and we're gonna take
another one oh you don't want Fort yeah
cuz at that point it's a scrap
yeah the premium luck medium luck
still no Legendary's though I left group
no Legendary's oh that's creepy I went
to at PAX East they had a panel and
dignities they had a panel about how
they make the animated cards and I'm
really curious I mean I I don't remember
a lot of it but basically it was like
like yeah it's about 15 hours per card
to make it creamy 'm cuz it's like art
but then on top of that it looks like
there's like a 3d model yes I do they do
the design a 3d model for it
that like hums the art on top yeah
that's so much yeah the supernovae says
dude stop making me feel so bad with
these creepy hums okay I'm gonna wait
for him to tell me which one to pick
here cuz they're small these are some
good ones yeah
I hope he's still in the chat Oh which
one uh what do you think he's gonna say
I'm gonna say well the Crone seems
really good if you have the other two
like you have the other two he's saying
saying oh the dragon right
unless unless you play dwarf I'll make
you better know though all right we're
good
just are you just joining us we are
opening keg packs in Gwent and also if
you have any questions the one of the
developers is in here right now you know
in the twitch chat so feel free to ask
him questions he's giving us tips on
what we should kick is well Jake's also
been getting an extraordinary amount of
premium cards and I'm very upset by it I
really like how you get to pick like
they show three you pick one I like that
too you said epidemic yeah I like that a
lot and I like that they let you know as
well keep your already habit that's it's
really nice take that because it looks
cool I like the art haven't had a
haven't had a premium in a while though
no maybe I dried them all up yeah we got
20 more he's a clan is that the one you
picked
no I don't think so but I had a couple
of I have a couple of those I'm gonna
take this though because wait yeah I
want this one
come on okay once it over those games a
bell pizza pie it's free you can pick it
up yeah PC you can download it over on
GOG if you playstation or xbox you can
just go download it for free yes i'll
dudn't premium and you're another I have
this one too but you want here's the
thing though
cuz you if you don't care you can always
um scrap it you'll get more I think
right um
he said you don't get actually you get
dust or something like that right I'll
take it
yeah please don't ask questions about
cyberpunk
oh yeah just went well like or like what
his favorite part is actually what is
your favorite card if you are listening
I'm curious Oh Johnny
oh man yeah he says no extra scraps with
more dust upgrade premium or doubt so
that's cool so you could get it oh I
feel like since I'm playing probably go
with this fat deer I have all my
business card yeah so actually when I
was at when I was at Projekt RED oh he
says no apparently we might have better
grab the wrong one
oh no oh did you get it oh honey oh he
got he got we're fixing it takes Katie's
gonna mom no no we apologize our BOTS
spamming another one he says king of
beggar's I I think I have king all right
thanks des but yes so when I went there
the Glenn team has went like they have
the card and then on the back is their
contact info I took a lot of them that's
rad
do you think they'll ever make um disco
versions of some of these the way they
did special editions for everyone oh
that would be really cool but I think
because one thing I don't know if you
had any of the I didn't I'll take that
but it was really hard to play that in
real life because you have to really
keep right around and I think this would
be even tougher in real life because
would because now there's more things
that play right very loose though it'd
be more balanced is that it would be
I'm another friend it's kind of when you
realize like this game's balance but if
they did make actual cards I would buy
them I was so fast I was want them to
learn exactly it's like I don't know if
I'd actually want to play it but I'd
like that part yeah so good yeah he's he
agrees Gwent in real life would be super
complicated right yeah um it's same with
like hearthstone right I just having to
track all these stats yeah the plans for
box additions you have a nightmare cell
uh yeah I do have a nice ooh
so we took that already you're not one
of those I kind of want to go with this
oh but these are both Angela she's fire
alight 'add who let's wait let's yeah
let's see what he says but yeah if there
was a box addition he said go love it
the middle guy I really like that good
though like the look it's it's good art
that's my friends I'm like well I want
that cord cuz it looks cool
my fingers are crossed it I'll get
another one 13:39 Cash when we can open
up a bonus one bonus one oh wait I
didn't even look
[Music]
I'll have any of this so I'm gonna take
just Adam yeah oh okay well you already
got three strategies matrix I like how
when you do get a premium card the troll
says movie card if you listen Oh movie
car oh really
does respond to this okay we already got
the already got free of that so I'll go
with put this as I saw him playing it
freshly all right ten left and left dang
man you got so many cards
Oh Oh another good one I wouldn't be
still in the chat haven't seen him in
various Oh give us some advice yeah I
kind of want create two lesser guardians
on the top of your opponent's deck oh so
that's how I drew those two
he says the Guardian yeah yeah oh so
that's how I drew those that's kind of
cool cousin you know exactly what they
are going to play still no no no how
much gold of course look at this this is
there's an oh there we go
speak of the devil goodie it looks like
when you hover over them even from
behind I don't know if that supposed to
be there but I could still see that gold
right got that gold oh and you got a
movie go on oh don't say it listen I
wasn't paying attention
uh-huh I don't think I heard him
apparently he's super good cool man I
feel like I'm gonna be out of computing
again playing you have to buy a pack of
40 just to keep up tomorrow
all right six left seven left what do
you think um well nothing to another
emissary you think so you so I can have
a full set of them help is you gonna are
you doing this for you still I have
three so shouldn't done that oh well
they were all bronze I don't have any of
this or this why not so after this we
got to get in we got to get your
collection we got a scrap and then we
should we should build a deck okay okay
morkul argh oh yeah I was gonna say his
better be like a resurrect thing ooh
Oh mad man Lugo's all right we got a
what do I pick Oh Philip
okay these to make apparently Morgan
Park is really good you are people are
bored out about work Park
well I got more Park yeah I just needed
to sell we need to decide this one I
love all the sorcerer like hey I'd love
to get all those but I don't use this
deck at all are you saying
killing Bickle forts they go for its
they go for its sure works is it is
outtie yeah yes okay anyway so that
actually is one card that they showed
the reaming without so see like he like
looks crazy lighting ahead on fire it's
super cool I was just saying I want the
premium version of that
Premium is another one that got none of
these just got the egg in the middle one
I'm getting really lucky okay so I have
him already I don't use duty that much I
like him I it would be cool to have all
the crumbs but the other option to get
the other clan awfully you know that's
the problem uh yeah we could rather make
a pretty good uh he says a guy on the
right what kind of deck should we make
do you think uh he sang in the chat that
we could prob a canola card no card deck
let's do that then we'll have Chat Chat
come up with a name for the no for our
deck we make I like that
yeah chases milf guard thanks Tay I
probably spelled that wrong oh this
mouse
I know I don't know why it started doing
this yeah it was fine when you were
lying earlier right yeah I'm gonna take
this okay that was all of them let's
let's buy one yeah I was going on last
one I'm feeling it I'm sitting gold you
feeling gold see whoa hey let's do it
I'm feeling gold oh dude apparently we
now do that epidemic was a premium oh
did I miss
yeah we weren't paying attention messed
up oh no no gold oh damn oh well I think
I got pretty lucky in terms of premium
right yeah oh what a scrub I know
oh that's the problem with like doing it
while I'm like trying to like right
we're trying to look at we're not paying
attention
oh okay did we get a good name oh yeah
what's up versus had to scrap some cards
yeah scrap some cards first head of your
cards in your collection and the
collection lets you look at the premium
cards you just see them in black and
white so if you want to see like them
okay
that's nice you actually like it a
little sense what they look like so if
you go back you can just hit Neal spare
cards oh sweet any legendaries yeah we
got what like two golds yeah can we yeah
I think we can filter them right yes if
you go to at the bottom there's filters
so these are the ones we have but it the
ones we got during it
do you remember I mean I remember don't
see him we got her when did we get her I
thought you got her yeah but I didn't
pick her oh maybe you're right oh maybe
she's one of the ones that just comes
with the maybe oh here we go so that's
new one we got yeah we got yesterday I
am he is no guard yeah we got tybor and
I think that was it or was there one
other one
someone says premium mistake I'm a is
that the deck name okay and tybor yeah
okay we will make rights
alright let's quick deck yeah forget
mega deck here we don't wanna spend like
too much so it'll probably be like the
best deck we could make because we don't
want to spend yeah - too much time okay
um should we start with golds sure so I
think we have to use the two new ones
right like oh yeah I want to do Klatte
deploy what is clash trigger disability
only if neither player has passed okay
boost self by 15 an opponent draws
revealed bronze card wow that's pretty
good
well so on since we could craft a yeah
right yeah we could on we have probably
enough material to craft some cards as
well okay um well let's we'll do that
later
ah big ol Ford's destroy an ally then
play the top card from your deck
including Gold's or clash destroying
enemy ven opponent viel bronze will take
my spray gun yeah
timer three destroy the highest units
Olivia he's given us some advice in the
chat here okay let's see here well now
yeah he's a right there okay and decree
royal decree I think this is thankful
yes
um alright well there's our four so four
yep those okay Silver's what do we want
from silver this card's kind of cool I
don't know if this fits into a certain
strategy that I yeah unless I'm not I'm
not very in tune with a nilfgaard he
says get the Dragons oh yeah good call
give any other dragons maybe in bronze
let's just go back and focus on silver
okay
the Guardian he says get the Guardian
okay and then get Peter Peter Brown yeah
get Peter price oh yeah I like Peter um
so we still have room for a couple more
mmm that one premium card you got so
spawn trimmers clear skies or bright
biting frogs pretty good he says the
premium yeah okay okay um we can fit two
more Silver's in here Jan van
I don't know a van is I don't know
either nine strength the nine strength
this one okay let's go this one said
he's really good what does he do a clash
each player draws a card including
Gold's the card drawn by opponent is
revealed it's very good and then and
then all rich that's when we just bowled
Floyd discard a card in your hand
including Gold's then create in your
hand the card of the same color from
your opponent's deck he sinks scorch
scorch okay yeah it seems like a good
yeah it's a good one
all right bronze saundra bronze we just
got to fill it up now yeah oh boy so it
seems like clash seems to be something
they're using I don't know I usually
play with spies but it seemed I don't
know if this deck spies are the best
right he's saying golems golems let's
see if I can find them and we have any
golems
you know what happening alright never
mind alright well apparently if we did
of Gollum's it's a good way to go and yo
yeah so that's the other thing is the
only leader I have I use the leader day
- oh that's what he was doing - Oh use
your leader to get the golems to show up
oh I see you can pull him back and then
from that smart yeah and there's it's
probably why we took this card - cuz he
can do the same thing yeah
dang yeah well if you ever get some
golems yeah pretty slick golem deck okay
I will just fill this and then yeah
let's say let's start just filling it
and we'll put these guys in because
there maybe not we had some specific
advice we can do we can do that yeah
okay here synergy Imperium forces look
at the end of the new deck if it's a
bronze game - armor silver boots elf but
one if it's a gold promote that seems
pretty cool
you got one premium version - oh we're
going to put that in for sure as I get
the cow tosser do I have that I just
search oh yeah I don't know if it's
called Cal toss it huh oh wait it is
yeah rot tosser righto sir
it's funny cow carcass on your phone so
this is the night as well fire bucket
over in the YouTube chats this is quite
today actually a lot of excitement going
on in d twitch chat we have one of the
co-creators of Gwent giving us a deck
building advice right now
[Music]
okay okay and then you said the night
yeah
switchbacks right now you have all you
want just bronze so
there are blast 10 strengths one oh yeah
that's probably good some brings a good
point that we could um we can maybe just
craft the Imperial golems oh yeah I we
should probably look late let's go let's
wrap the deck save it and then we could
what
let me save X's right now and then just
see if I can crabby gonna craft them cuz
yeah that's know everybody see if he's
got one more tit
he thinks we should add first oh okay
well I'm gonna craft him now let's gonna
craft him that will get back in in the
pipe man alright remember that ok
pikemen alright uh are the golems I
don't think I think golems are probably
neutral huh they said Imperial golems at
all they might be no garden oh did I
spill that rule no there enough guard
okay oh my gosh
I'm in neutral still okay no guard
oh here we go these guys yeah
crops um oh yeah man dude you can crap
food you can craft all three of these
really easily let's do it should I do
one premium - that's up to you I don't
think you have a any dust okay okay yes
so definitely crap clothes it seems like
you they are okay pikemen there we go
you're just on them yeah oh yeah these
guys are cool okay we have 25 is that is
that good
uh wait for a specia professional yeah
any last advice anymore it seems like
everyone thinks you should call it milf
guard all right I think I think that's
rasa vu winte this is good
Goods the thumbs up alright alright we
got name it yo yo you have to back out
to name it okay amuse deck
have it on capslock that you've got that
jeez I can't title oh my gosh I can't
type
Chris how did they fill it in the game
it's not actually like that no they
don't actually spell like that it's that
isn't it right yeah
okay that was such low-hanging fruit
jokes been made so many times but the
chat wanted it okay
gotta give each other they want alright
let us try our new our new milf guard
elf guard day as you can see the other
person's deck name okay so their thing
saying the thing about the golems is you
don't actually want them to be in your
hand
okay so seems like if we have them at
our hand we want to get them out not any
of [ __ ] mate because I think it what it
is is you're basically like summoning
them
I'm doing that is but one punishment for
traitors and they appear automatically
yeah yeah so you have any yeah get up
get them out of there okay we don't need
more you want the Guardian yeah maybe
play some of those guys
see how that goes okay let's try it this
guy's saying milf guard really hey that
we let me let it fit up the chat that's
not our fault
okay
Humber - really random card notice all
roads lead to new leaf cart
do you just now you saying start with
the Guardian Oh star with the Guardian
oak is have already engine that was
mastered their goals it's a good point
OB kit yeah cuz now I know he's gonna
draw neatly know how it's starting
hmm
it hurts em oh we said now the cow get
advice here whoops cow do a timer
destroy the lowest units on the road and
banish that unit that's pretty that is
pretty cool on the chest says now a cow
may be my favorite piece of rice okay
hmm do random card from your hand what
do you think hmm
just gonna no nice play that dude this
guy's in trouble
I told me to use on Mir would I use a
mirror what should I use a mirror on I
feel like I'm cheating I just have and
get the golem again oh dang okay
oh oh that's so dirty patience is not a
virtue I am known to have and then play
it again and then that's what he they're
gonna draw good do I'm gonna pass I'm
gonna make a nilfgaard deck now yeah
that's them that's so good
just like here have happened nothing man
oh that's great uh I shouldn't keep
these yeah the whole game he just has to
like easy its guns oh that is really
good Oh hmm I'm sure I saw it developer
strategy they're saying I should just
pass and give him this look because he's
gonna have to burn through a card little
bit the same mine he says don't do don't
do t that's amore high more deburr tybor
says wait as the last card okay okay so
what's he do exactly
uh so it's a clash so if we're both
still in the game he gets boosted by
fifteen and then I draw got in it
alright yeah yeah so he's really good
I'll throw down corpse over there
my studies are more important than this
fire Marcus's this is middle-age poker
it has the the bluffing elements yeah of
poker which I like about it so I may
have timed this wrong but I think what's
gonna happen is hopefully a card will go
to my turn
that's hats it'll go back to him and now
that's gonna kill those right - so now
he's down again he's got playing on a
card
if he wants to win what she probably
should also that's interesting that you
can see that this is not a you see it's
a okay you just know what it is yeah
bang and he's gonna draw more this Oh
dang I'll finish redrawing or over
Jewish
didn't see that one coming damage units
by two and two then but once we'll hold
off on that trigger you're it's so I'm
gonna do this I wonder if the column
space no they don't
okay okay that's it nothing well yeah
alright not golf flopping
audible tram it must triumph yeah I want
to I just make sure I like get the most
out of what I end up playing yeah I
guess I might just do this now oh I
guess I I didn't realize I chew on
I stride above all to be chopped him
down by one oh he knows I have this too
oh yeah
it is how I punish those who attack me
Oh what time what's that leader dude I
don't know
route of it no lost okay so I want to
play him now right because if I don't
he'll pass and you're happy right yes
but you drew
oh he draws okay yeah so
what you got one card to play oh that's
a good thing uh güven the Jaspers card
database go to Gwent d be calm you
getting you can look at a full database
of all the card in this state so das
reflected in a pond for the nice guy
alright well I think we won that I make
some for now come on dang that deck was
deadly thank you for the about yes thank
you so much um cuz I'm gonna lose now
real bad what are you like oh I think
that's is it's probably a good spot to
end this on yeah so thank you very much
to everyone who joined us thank you to
want to give it a shot how to pronounce
his name uh I tried Rafal before but it
was wrong but thank you so much for
stopping by and giving us advice yes
playing against us
yeah and make sure to follow him on
Twitter it's it's at Gwent bro I think
it's pretty good great ordered a pretty
good but yeah thank you for stopping by
and hanging out with the twitch in with
our twitch group and everything like
that and thank you guys for watching
this was a fun stream as Ryan in the
YouTube chat pointing out we're going to
have a ton of live streams all next week
because it is III week we're going to be
doing pre-imposed shows for all the
press conferences and we're going to
have the press conferences themselves
and then during e3 proper we're going to
be doing like demo we're going to have a
demo stage which I'm going to be
directing which is pretty exciting so my
first time doing that
and then Ross grandpa co-op stage with a
bunch of people down there like kind of
funny and stuff that should be pretty
rad
anything else I'm missing tomorrow is
the lobby and we're gonna see we're
supposed to have the we're gonna have
the the UK and Australian people yeah on
the lobby so that should be pretty
exciting and yeah thanks for tuning in
guys I think that's about it thank you
bye